[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we want and
today we have dough boy to the show you
know bumpy start you're good but it was
mentioned to me that people are
requesting you to be on regarded sir i
like where did you get your name from i
used to sell drugs in sacramento okay
there's kind of a thing you know people
needed it so they kind of labeled no I'm
totally kidding
what was your inventory like no but
really where I got it from I was like I
wasn't like a liar when I was a kid
it's nice to tell other kids that I was
the younger dough boy and boys in the
hood oh man I just rent boys in the hood
and I was lying and my name just kind of
stuck Doughboy so I'm a fraud and people
just believed you they really believe me
I was kind of like by myself and [ __ ]
but one of our good friends was now with
this no longer a part of the show
anymore
okay yeah but we don't care about him
anymore
okay I could be your new Sacramento
you're talking Sacramento [ __ ]
you have to really show Sacramento
though cuz that guy always show
Sacramento
he's like Sacramento's the dopest it is
I got I got nine one six tattoo them on
you call it macrame no now we don't like
you people call it and we're not the
bailout - oh you're from the bay [ __ ]
that it's not the bay do you guys use
cleansing sacraments not in LA I'm doing
one nightmare see yeah cuz you're all
you said you're on a cleanse
yeah this isn't even Jews but it was
Green I said [ __ ] it it'll work it's
much up from the fit matcha
what are you doing it for I want to lose
weight man okay Ron I've been a weight
loss competition that I think I'm gonna
lose so between you and your friends
yeah Maxum man keV man come oh yeah yeah
remember that okay I wasn't really a
dumb bet for me to do yeah when we
started out with like 60 pounds heavier
than him oh no you could lose more
weight right that's what I was thinking
so I should have done a percentage loss
I said I'll weigh less than your mother
in August 21st it's ten weeks away you
could do a lot in ten weeks yeah so I'm
in a jam I'm drinking juice so we'll see
what happens
a fair bet would have been how many
pounds exactly what you can do coke
that's not thinking cocaine always work
so you know I'm saying oh okay no I mean
cocaine cocaine and juice form because
he's on a juice cleanse you too but you
know I actually YouTube how to roll a
blunt learned did you learn well I
better yeah I could roll months now yeah
yeah but the fact that I had to go to
you to I felt like oh wait were you like
rolling them before you like manicure
you probably never had roll that I could
never roll the blood and I just wanted
to survive
yeah dude that's YouTube it's a niche
medium dude you can you can fix an old
clock on YouTube yeah you can do
everything on it you just you just
either need a white guy that has dreads
or a ex-con they roll blunts amazing I
always get leery of the white guys with
dreads Birkenstocks I don't know they
just I feel like they once you get the
dreadlocks they give you the burgers do
I know why go with dreads and he always
did this thing about marijuana where
he's like dude it's like it's not just a
drug man it's like [ __ ] excuse me
it's a religious experience yeah
everybody says that it's so annoying am
I just like what you like it's fine yeah
you
to go all aboard with the selling of it
and the only way to get rid of it you
got to cut it out you got to like
literally cut your hands rights things
so what brought you to LA um I just was
I was doing music a ton of time in my
life and being I really wasn't making no
money off of it nobody wanted to hear me
rap so my best friend kept telling me I
was funny so he was I owe them some
money so he was like yo just go do this
open mic ain't got to pay me back I said
okay and then I people just saw a good
friend reacted to me and so you just did
stand up out of nowhere did you stand up
out of nowhere it was right when my
daughter was born I was around 26 at the
time so was it hard the first time no I
just went there I didn't even know
really how to put a job together
whenever have butterflies or anything
you just went up and you started yeah I
just went up there and just started
talking and it was it was just you
probably got used to like just
performing from rapping and stuff I was
used to being in front of audiences and
[ __ ] so in always like comedy so when
that worked I was just like okay this is
this is cool but I still kind of kept my
dream of rapping alive so I said you
know I'm gonna go to LA and I'm gonna
get on wild and out and you know thanks
to Nick Cannon and I was able to do that
there for season oh okay then did you
get booted from the show no I didn't get
booted from the show they just never you
know you see every season they'll call
you back amen and then one season and
they phoned in rings I was like okay but
it was cool I wasn't like it wasn't it
was definitely a career builder like a
momentum builder for me so they're not
even went on to go work with our death
I've been without I was without death
for the past four almost five years I
feel like they're replacing all the
comedians with influencers yeah that's
that's kind of like the wave but this
day they still have their staples they
know they still got like Chico Carlos
they still got like their core guys and
I still bring in different people but
yeah it's just it's really competitive
like everybody's really good and really
funny
oh so it's more like skill-based you
thought because in the crazy [ __ ] was
sometimes people would be on the episode
and we feel me and you think oh man
watch this episode I killed it you
[ __ ] se gotta edit it out have you
seen a guy like bomb-ass on that show
and they pull them aside like this isn't
funny [ __ ] you like that kind of thing
like a team a team atmosphere so it's
never like [ __ ] you you're stupid or
you're wack it's just we're gonna put
this guy in because he's funnier like
you don't say so it's just very very
competitive at the same time it's like
it's almost like playing on the Warriors
it's like everybody's just really good
so you know I definitely love the
experience like and I'm sitting there
for four seasons and I have one season
where I was a creative consultant so I
love it those guys are still cool they
still reach out here and I still work
when they can there so how many hours
was the taping the Taipei's would be
like maybe per episode I'd be like an
hour hour and a half they would just
shoot volume stuff like a whole lot of
stuff but each episode is about an hour
and a half but then you keep putting a
bunch of episodes in one day exactly so
we would shoot like maybe two episodes a
day sometimes if they were really
advantageous three so that was
definitely cool was just hard work it
was just heard the pay sucks you don't
remember you ever see the high-pitched
inflection nah but more than anything
you just create the opportunity and
platform they put that out in front of
millions of people so people still to
this day no need to people watching MTV
- I when I first came a shot in New York
and then they shot some seasons in LA
then they started moving around if
they've shot in Brooklyn now they saw
too soon Atlanta so they move around man
the show actually got a real big
resurgence in like they were doing tours
and they were like selling out
basketball arenas and says wow went
viral cuz I remember for a minute I
stopped watching and then it started
coming back again I was like oh she did
saw an error still yeah I think they
definitely think that Debbie was a
transition time of them kind of
adjusting to the digital boom yeah from
TV cuz they were just mostly a TV show
and I think there was like when they
have brought us back you know to bring
the show back I think that's when they
really started figuring out like
algorithms in how stuff goes by word
yeah so is more popular than ever now is
it really it's more popular now than
ever
oh yeah and it's not MTV - no more it's
on MTV oh it is - [ __ ] wife audition for
the show opera and she got it but then
the contract was like pretty nuts like
it was like you're exclusively here and
you have to like so it was not a good
match yeah when I signed when I got on
like I
done nothing so I was like why and with
me it was different like I had moved out
here to get on that so that's why I
actually have it tattooed on my arm
yes that was a career starter for you
absolutely I got all that there's no
tattoo so I didn't people just think
about are you gonna just have to
everything that you do your brother's
right here but now AMC movie theater
like I was on CSI once I was a body soul
are the two most influential things that
I do so they mean a lot to me so yeah
it's like where's your resume look at
this BAM I was all out and out okay good
thing was wild and out and not like you
know [ __ ] jeopardy
the crazy thing was when I got the
tattoo though then the season came back
up after that to get you know renewed
and I wasn't on a scene as I look at it
to where it's facing away I mean it was
just I mean it was a very rare the
situation of I made a goal and I did
that [ __ ] like yes yes shout out to make
cannon boys over without man it pretty
tight like you know I'm say I think when
I first started working there I was like
he hired me we're best friends so that's
kind of what I sued hanging out he was
always just you know cool you always
dropped a lot of gay a flat tire can you
call him could you call Nick Cannon
right now he's a good dude man he's
always so mean on the left so number
respectfully getting inside info but the
morano's when I met her she was super
cool man I was like she came to
backstage to the show she was just super
nice I was just in awe his vision of
love is one of my favorite songs ever in
the world probably like number three so
yeah so me and I was super cool man so
yeah man you put that song in my head
how's it go t-they me
so faithfully all that I want for
Christmas is you that's you know that
wasn't a rebate that was an original
song that she wrote I do she wrote this
is she's gonna be paid forever off that
it's all just anonymous for Christmas
that's a Christmas staple yeah I hope
she doesn't get caught in a pedophile
cases because there's so many art Kelly
songs right that are part of my
upbringing mm-hmm and then now because
of that like sometimes when I hear his
music it makes me feel weird
and that song is part of my childhood
too and then if she's been touching I
don't know little things here and there
when I count something at least so
jealous if she was because I'm like I
was that age you telling me I had an
opportunity no I always thought about
that's inside so these people that that
end up doing [ __ ] up [ __ ] yeah yeah
but what if their music is ingratiated
in your memory like what about the
people that got married and we're dads
it's a step in the name alone how can
you take that away from your memory
that's like Woody Allen movies are
incredible I've never seen them thank
you by yourself on that we all agree
nope I don't even know one time midnight
Paris yeah I like that movie great movie
I've never seen a Meryl Streep movie
what I'm most proud of this I was like
that's my favorite here like I don't
watch Bale Street would I just I can't
remember what I never seen Devil Wears
Prada I know she's in a ton of other
things yeah what's that holiday movie
that we like a holiday movie the one
where they swap seats it's not and it's
called the holiday
what do you got the movies Annie Hall no
no no any home what's wrong Woody Allen
so he's like [ __ ] his kid I guess
what he adopted a dog he adopted an
asian girl and then he married her yeah
just cause he's he's [ __ ] his adopted
daughter we we gotta hate his movies now
yeah adopted a child marry her subject
when she became of age I think I don't
know how they came out that they liked
each other what is there something
together right I think they're still
together [ __ ] are we talking about what
we don't because he has fantastic cinema
and we shouldn't you should have never
seen a Woody Allen movie [ __ ] I
don't like not tell you though if I saw
Nick Cannon mrad together
i bypassed mechanical straight tomorrow
and be like can I have your autograph
please later lose this Mariah Carey I'll
give you that but what is Murr I mean
there's no shade to Marah but what is
much Muraya done in the past alleged to
me it's been relevant and successful
like two years now then you get all that
right it was the opener he was like he
used to warm up the crowd for all that
but none of this content actually made
me like I don't have a memory like I've
watched it but Mariah has like I get
that my elementary school
- Mariah you know here's the thing not
really but your good friend by the way
your very good friend
you're having his back and that's tight
I like that about you okay but Nick
Cannon can go to Target and the cans
gonna be fine no I don't think I don't
think so no he's very much as you know
but Mariah Carey gets back important I'm
you're right do the doors at Target and
she gets picked apart she's talking fun
I think you're right so they're both
really big stars I mean with me I papi
if I seen and I didn't know either one
of them I probably running it cuz I'm a
fan of his work yeah but I understand
why somebody would run them right yeah
are you trying to get called back
I feel like Mariah's like legacy and
claim though is so much more greater
because if you go to a senior citizen
bingo game and Nick Cannon's there no
one's gonna notice who he is but they'll
know who Mike Carey is this is John she
has very time this music music shameless
its international of all the things that
Nick is known for music ain't ya the
number one thing's for sure that was a
good dish Oh clowns on him because of
the music he made but see that's a big
turn that into it like Nick is actually
very smart like he's actually the
richest person on there so making the
most money and he could take the most
jobs yeah because he's like it doesn't
matter what I'm the rich everybody will
get like you can't wrap all these the
Atmos clock do this I own everything
here he's paying tattooed on his arm II
better be back home on an own-goal word
I like glitter more than Wilding out was
not good I really wonder if Mariah Carey
could like shatter glass of your voice
oh that was a rumor
that's a banshee as voice well it's good
to have you guys what else do you guys
want to know about me so you said you
had a daughter I leave one daughter
I do another she's 13 I almost caught a
baby mama last time ago well last
December
Colleen had a one-night stand last bust
it all up in there yeah so I talked so
she can't see me I'm sure is like y'all
I'm pregnant I was just like I mind you
I didn't know nothing about it it was
really just a what are you doing
life okay that's what she tried to save
it there's only one guy he's all wild
and I said look man if this kids not
mine like you don't owe me nothing just
be honest let me know if it's somebody
else's said no no I wouldn't do that to
you whatever whatever so I'm a guy cool
so we go the whole thing like I'm there
for all the time I'm making sure she's
good I don't you see me I help deliver
the baby
Wow smart the baby's baby the door a
dedicated chic absolutely since it off
three they've added you are not the
father I was like God did you have to
secretly swamp oh she knows oh she was
just like do you let me go through all
of the things she probably needed backup
during the whole pregnancy I don't know
did that hurt did you kind of like the
baby in you're like oh I'll show you
guys I won't put it on here but I was
holding the baby I was like Park is my
daughter had kept asking for a sibling I
was like doing getting a sister this
Christmas did you announce that you just
had a daughter I did it that's the thing
so this is what I did though cuz you
know me and care of the guy you guys
haven't before we have a podcast so I
was so certain the baby was mine I was
like I'll get the results live on the
air because I hadn't told nobody yeah
solve it I'll get for you like you sure
you want to do that I'm like absolutely
something the babies will be mine you
read the [ __ ] results I was like so
goddamn lucky though were you like
relieved like I was relieving later cuz
I do want more kids and I would kind of
like resigned to the fact that oh this
is gonna be cool but I don't really want
another co-parenting situation I would
rather be with the woman that I'm gonna
tough yeah yeah so it's definitely some
of the best times I've had on YouTube is
watching you are not the father
yeah when the guy sits there and then he
starts crying a little bit I [ __ ] it
it's all good this is crazy me I feel
like man I feel like we have a tough
some tile know if you guys heard about
it there was some it happened like in
the East Coast this girl was in college
and I guess they did some like
ancestry.com thing for a college term
paper and she found out her dad was not
her dad and then her mom comes pain and
she was just like yes I see was like his
best friend's kids my husband my my
son's father but he knows but he knows
right so it's different when you just
tells my a this is a kid like dude I
went back in time and impregnated you so
yeah man I was um so yeah I kind of
messed up my dating life I was married
for 84 days what congratulations
interesting huh how did that so he
decided to just go for it because
drinking a lot used to be alcoholic um
ha ha yeah I was drinking a lot of the
time and it felt like a good idea and
then like three weeks and I was just
like was it one of those drive through
Vegas marry Oh
she was actually that girl that I had
been dating and shout-out to her too
because it was just my fault but we have
been dating for like on and off for like
five years and then like I was like well
we get back together we all come back as
a husband it was the most ridiculous
wedding ever I got married at a park
with a mobile priest I got married with
some cargo shorts on uh some team Jordan
shoes I wrapped my vows nobody liked my
verse McDonald's for the reception I had
a fish fillet to over them I like it
we've suffered during the well the sofa
during it but I was like but all the
times around it I was just drinking in
this pre comedy you know this is this
happen in 2015 that's amazing so yeah
like you were still expressing your
comedy through that yeah cuz you're
wrapping your vows you know what you're
doing no but not really with that
thought I was like man this is really
gonna work and then I was just like we
just I was just in a place where I
didn't need to be with nobody at the
time I was just I needed to figure some
[ __ ] out and Wow yeah I was married for
84 days we'll be right there
did you have the priest the mobile peace
drop drop drop a beat for you know is
there like and I was like anybody Bob
your head to the beaten like everybody
was just like this hurry up you made a
buck can be big there was not happening
there everyone was offbeat go the kids
that yet at happening next to us kiss a
soccer ball in the middle of the well
Mary oh my god my life has been crazy
hallo oh yes well welcome to the show
thank you for having me
now you guys know me a little better
let's have some fun you know Larry
[Music]
you